there's an imbalance here John you know  it's been 100% focused on our  relationship by Saudi Arabia and quote  our national interest without any focus  at all on American values what is the  cost of the fact that the administration  isn't taking care of that imbalance  isn't standing up for the values that  you're talking about look we're the  standard bearer in the world I mean we  are still in spite of you know where  people may view us to be this very day  we are still the shining city on the  hill and when we degrade ourselves by by  not by not focusing on the moral values  what it does is send a signal to the  world that you know there's only one  thing we care about and that is money if  you spend money with us and lavish us  with praise you can get away with  whatever your wish